Let's go next to taffin from California.
That is not a name I've seen before, taffin.
Oh, no.
I don't know where my parents got their name
from.
Interesting.
You've never asked.
I mean, actually, I do know where it's from,
but it's like such a silly story like.
But Mario.
No, but my question is, this is something
I'm kind of noticing and it's kind of like
a question it's raised in my head that I think
might actually have some implications for
the Republican Party.
OK, but I recently saw this video of like
a bunch of like Trump supporters in Georgia,
and it was some like rally or protest or whatever.
And one of the guys got up and started shouting
about how they were going to destroy the Republican
Party for betraying them.
Right.
And this is something I'm starting to think
like see more and more.
And I think it's more of a trend now where
I'm seeing more infighting in the Republican
Party rather than actually like like going
towards any, like Democrats and stuff.
And looking back, I think one of the things
that made the Republican Party so strong was
they're like coalition building.
And what I'm thinking is that what do you
think?
That there's a possibility that, like how
radicalized that the Republicans and Trump
have made the base could actually start like
making blowback against the Republicans less?
We're seeing more and more of a bunch of like
Republicans like obviously they've supported
some of this stuff, but they can't support
all of it.
And the moment you know that, they go against
it, like we saw with Tucker Carlson, the people
sort of like slamming back against them.
And do you think that could start making some,
like, blowback or repercussions to the Republican
Party?
I would love to think that the answer is yes.
But I think the most likely scenario is that
once Trump is gone and Joe Biden is sworn
in, there's this phrase return to the mean.
And I think that we are going to see Republicans
basically go back to where they were before
Trump, which is Democrats really are the enemy.
You'll still have these fringes of the Republican
Party that will say the problem is the Republican
Party isn't right enough or whatever the case
may be.
But I think for the most part, you'll see
Republicans going back to exactly what they
were, where you see the low tax pro-business
conservatives, allied with the evangelicals,
allied with the libertarians, all united that
Democrats are really bad people, really bad.
They're socialists, communists, et cetera.
And I don't think that the fracturing of the
Republican Party that you're seeing right
now is going to persist.
Now, I could be wrong.
And if it does persist, that could be great
for the left.
But I'm not optimistic.
I think the Republican Party will go right
back to what they were before Donald Trump.
Yeah, you're probably right.
I just got excited seeing that in Georgia
because the runoff is coming out.
Yeah.
I think I also saw people, some some Republicans
saying, oh, we need to punish the Republican
Party by not voting at all in Georgia in the
short run.
I thought it was going to, which sounds great.
I mean, if I was ever going to vote like Democrat,
but I could see them, like, just not voting.
Exactly.
And I hope that happens because it could actually
I mean, the polls are really tight in both
of those races.
They're essentially statistical ties.
If if a million more Democrats register and
a million Republicans decide not to vote or
something, you know, whatever numbers that
alone could flip the results and give Democrats
the Senate, which would just be amazing.
No.
So I guess at least in the short term, there's
some benefit to be made out of that.
Yeah, I do think Republicans will go back
to what they were, but in the next two and
a half months, there may actually be an advantage
to be gained from from the chaos.
And let's hope that that's the case.
OK, well, thanks for taking my question, David.
All right.
My pleasure.
I appreciate very much.
Appreciate the phone call that is going to
do it for calls for today.
As always, you know my deep apologies to everybody
I was not able to get to.
But there it's a good problem to have that
there are more callers than time for calls.
Hope everybody in the U.S. has a great Thanksgiving.
I'll take a few audience questions after the
break and then we'll be back at it very strongly
at the start of next week